tu as assuré
très peu de gens dans le monde sont
capables de le faire
tu pourrais être le meilleur
c'est la première fois qui s'organise ça
t'a presque jamais conduit j'ai couru
des milliers d'heures qu'est-ce que tu
racontes mais ça n'a rien à voir mon
fils vous croyez qu'un joueur pourrait
devenir pilote je ne crois sans le
moindre de toute façon
[Applaudissements]
vous devrez prendre des décisions en un
quart de seconde
qui pourront vous coûter la vie les
risques sont considérables
restent concentrés
tu démontres à tous les jeunes que rien
n'est impossible
je sais très bien de quoi je parle j'ai
pas la trouille
tu vas devoir prouver que tu es à ta
place que ça te plaise ou non tes dans
cette course et tu y restes
[Applaudissements]
oui chef